what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime opera
and today i will be breaking down deku's
recent
life-changing decision in the boku no
hero story
and i will be discussing his master plan
to defeat the villains and bring an end
to the chaos that has been plaguing the
hero society
heads up to anime onlys because this
video will contain
mha manga spoilers i will be discussing
the most recent events in the manga and
the manga
is far ahead of the anime at this point
the main focus of this video will be
analyzing deku's decision to leave the
ua
and become a vigilante and how this
decision
could be part of deku's master plan to
defeat the villains
and save japanese society if you enjoyed
the boku no hero content here on the
channel and you want us to keep it going
just leave a like
and comment it's a totally free way to
actively support
the channel and of course if you're new
to the channel or maybe you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you don't want to
miss our videos in the future you have
to go through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says
all finally big thank you to all of our
anime outpour patrons for making videos
like this possible
i'll talk more about patreon at the end
of this video so
the big question that we have to ask
ourselves is why exactly did deku decide
to leave the ua at first glance it seems
he just wanted to protect his fellow
students
since he is being directly targeted by
shigaraki
and all for one but what if there is
more to his decision
than that in recent chapters horikoshi
went
out of his way to mention that the ua
was the most
secure place for the students to be and
even the parents of the students were
invited to stay on the ua campus because
of how
safe it is on top of that principal nezu
asked for further government assistance
in order to make the ua
even safer but if the ua really is
so safe if it's like the safest place
for the students and their
families then does it make sense for
deku to leave
on the one hand he is protecting his
friends from a potential villain attack
but on the other hand if deku takes
himself
out of a safe area like the ua he could
be playing right into the hands of the
villains
deku may be making his friends safer by
leaving but he is also putting the
entire world in danger
by making it a lot easier for all for
one to potentially steal
one for all keeping one for all away
from all for one is
obviously in the best interest of
everyone
so by leaving a safe zone like the ua
deku is taking a huge risk
if all for one can get to him and steal
one for all
then it's pretty much game over the hero
society as it is right now
could not possibly stop a villain who
controls both one for all
and all for one and besides even though
deku is definitely the biggest target at
ua because of one for all he is still
not the
only target for the villains there are
plenty of other students and teachers at
ua who are well known to the villains
and whom the villains would love to take
out either for revenge or to prevent
them from posing a threat
in the future this includes bakugou
todoroki the big three
aizawa and many many more like yeah the
villains really want
deku but it's not like they would
completely lose interest in potentially
attacking the ua
just because deku left oh and that
reminds me how does the ua trader plot
point come into play here
has horikoshi completely abandoned this
plot point from the past
or is it about to finally become
relevant again
with the ua now being transformed into
what is essentially a maximum security
bunker
having a spy inside the ua is more
useful now to the villains than
ever before so are they about to
activate the trader once again
and if they do what will that mean for
the story
man i have been wondering about the ua
trader for almost
4 years now and i really hope that this
plot point will have some sort of payoff
eventually
by the way let me know down in the
comments whether you think that there is
a ua trader in the first place
and if you think that there is then who
do you think it is
i know that toru hagakure is a popular
option because her quirk allows her to
be the perfect spy
but my own personal theory is that it
could be principal
nezu i don't think that he is doing it
willingly i think that back when he was
experimented on by humans
ujjiko was somehow involved in those
experiments
and i think that he could have done
something to nezu that allows the
villains to get information from him
without nezu even realizing it
but that's all speculation without more
clues so let me know what you guys think
what are your theories
i'm always interested in hearing more
about the ua trader
now back to deku deku becoming a
vigilante
allows him to be more flexible and
independent in his actions
but he is still going to keep fighting
the villains and we saw him do exactly
that when he used
danger sense to detect muscular and then
stepped in to save shindo
from muscular so yeah it's not like deku
is about to like start hiding so that
all for one can't locate one for all
it's just not how deck
works this means that deku's decision to
become a lone wolf vigilante will expose
him to a lot more danger than if he had
just stayed at ua
but on the other hand this will also
allow deku to set a trap
for all for one if deku had remained
under constant protection
inside the ua he wouldn't have been able
to do much
against the villains but if he starts to
make a reputation for himself as a lone
wolf vigilante who has no official
affiliation to the ua
or the pro heroes system deku will
become the focus of
all of all for one's attention instead
of worrying about the ua and the pro
heroes
all for one will concentrate on tracking
down the lone wolf vigilante deku
by any means necessary but here's the
thing
if deku secretly stays in contact with
his friends at the ua
and with the pro heroes he can
eventually serve as
bait for trapping all for one and the
other villains
if deku can make all for one think that
he is now working completely on his own
all for one will be more likely to come
out of hiding before he and the other
villains are at their strongest
and before shigaraki's procedure has
been perfected i feel like all for one
won't be able to pass up on the
opportunity to steal one for all
from just one lonely kid so all for one
and the other villains are far
more likely to underestimate deku now
that he is on his
own and this could cost them dearly in
the end
so what if this whole decision to leave
the ua
is part of a larger plan right now
time is really working against the
heroes because society is crumbling and
they're spending all of their time
trying to put society back together
meanwhile all for one is probably hiding
somewhere
safe and working on perfecting
shigaraki's transformation
as soon as possible and if shigaraki's
procedure
is perfected it is likely that no one
will be able to stop him
so what if deku just wants to make all
for one think that he is acting as a
lone wolf so that he can lure him
and the other villains out of hiding
before shigaraki becomes virtually
unstoppable if all for one thinks that
he just has to take out one high school
kid and then he can have one for all
he might get reckless and if
all for one comes out of hiding and
attacks deku he could end up walking
right into a trap
laid by the pro heroes and the hero
students in collaboration with
deku so deku might be pretending to be a
lone wolf
but in reality he's working closely with
the other heroes and hero students
in order to bait all for one into a trap
so far we've been led to believe that
deku's decision to leave the ua was
motivated solely by the fact that he
wants to protect his fellow students
from being targeted by the villains
but i think that there might be more to
this decision than meets the eye
i think that deku might be setting an
elaborate trap for all for one and
shigaraki and deku's departure from the
ua
and his decision to become a vigilante
could all be just one part of his secret
master plan
after all if there really is a traitor
inside the ua
and deku is busy concocting a master
plan to take
out the villains it would make sense for
dekku to leave the ua so that his plan
doesn't
leak to the traitor and since deku
doesn't know who the traitor is
he has to assume that almost anyone
could be suspicious
but let me know what you guys think was
deku's decision to leave the ua
and become a lone wolf vigilante just
his way of protecting his friends
or is there more to the story and
if deku really is concocting a secret
master plan
how do you think that this plan will
ultimately unfold
be sure to share your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content
right here on the channel just leave a
like to let me know it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to the two disciples
of lord twego himself
alpha sigma and the red-haired raven
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
acquired respect pate heffa liam
thompson algetal
dr cortman dust and scarlet the toasted
chi
bang emperor taku spidey life canal
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis
and yuno finally thank you also to our
pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
rathune de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia
ted no ted i sparky 65 jessica lafond
fat boy games deadly saint and soul ray
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar gives
you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you